[Musique]
je m'éclate je me suis trompé
la roue tourne
[Musique]
de mistura
et
2 3 4
[Musique]
et
bon alors qu'est ce que je fais
maintenant julie julie j'ai dit casimir
à vous êtes là qu est il qu est ce que
ça vous n'auriez pas vu monsieur du snob
non si moi je l'ait vue formidable
casimir où et quand attends laisse moi
réfléchir des choix c'est très urgent
haut rhin à c'était ici même dans le
jardin oui quand c'était hier matin
c'est malin casimir vraiment dès que se
passe-t-il françois tu as l'air dans un
état parce que vous n'avez rien entendu
boue et toi casimir moi rien du tout
écoutez c'est incroyable mais mou mais
vous êtes surtout les deux ou quoi mais
mais ça s'est entendue dans toute l'île
tu sais on avait mis la musique de la
danse est très fort ça swingue accary
bhl mais tu nous as même pas dit que le
bruit s'agissait sont étrangers sur
aiguë qui vous glace les os on dirait
que quelqu'un installer une sirène
une sirène une sirène j'ai toujours eu
envie de rencontrer une sirène je les
trouve tellement adorable avec leur
petite queue de poisson je me remets
casimir et que j'ai pas de ce genre de
deux sirènes d'ailleurs qui sait très
bien qu'il n'existe pas de nous je te
parle d'une sirène d'alarmé
je ne vois pas qui aura pu installer une
si la rana larmes dans l'île aux enfants
c'est justement ce que je me mange julie
c'est pourquoi je cherche monsieur du
snop qui en tant que président de la
fête doit être au courant
[Musique]
nous pouvons alors là vous avez entendu
un bruit étrange tu crois que c'est
dangereux mais non casimir ce n'est pas
dangereux mais ça trouble de calme de
livres soit sans doute une façon de se
demander tolérable mais c'est tout alors
ces six a sonné en large toutes les deux
minutes ce ça va devenir invivable ici
au mans j'ai mûri mais qu'est ce qui
t'arrive
pourquoi tu ressembles plus comme ça je
ne suis pas en dire à quelle approche
mais n'ont quasiment aucun signal ne
peut pas approcher une sirène d'alarmé
ne se promènent pas dans le jardin mais
j'avoue que je suis comme casimir moi
j'ai eu l'impression que le son à
s'approchait là et vous avez rêvé tous
les deux voleurs le vent a apporté le
son jusqu'à vous j'entends dire j'ai
vraiment hâte à cette fois vous avez
raison le son s'est rapproché il ya
quelque chose
curieux dans cette plainte c'est
peut-être un mot un horrible monstre
auquel j miro du connais-toi beaucoup d'
horrible monstre vivant dans l'île aux
enfants
j'en connais un qui s c'est moi c'est
pas un gros monstre à l'heure et qu'est
ce que ça peut être il ya quelque chose
d'humain dans sur le monde sirène tu as
parfaitement raison julie il ya quelque
chose d'humain
j'ai vu bouger là bas
écoutez minutes rester derrière moi s'il
ya du danger je veux pas très frais ou
les choses approche on j'ai peur
attention voilà bonjour à tous que vous
avez vite il a tous les droits vous avez
des répondantes et gâtés du danger et
demi la petite jours mais ne feriez vous
pas des des vocalises l'instant où vous
m'avez entendu où j'en suis content
dix ans il est vrai que je le fais je
lis brême voit alors quand je me promène
dans la campagne ogm à faire quelques
délits canevas khalili c'était bien moi
je chantais tout en venant elle chante
elle de ces drogues pour courrier vous
eh bien nous avions pris pour une sirène
mais je comprends en deschamps
délictuelle chabot moeurs des sirènes
non non non une sirène d'alarmé
casimir c'est bien la première fois
qu'on se monte à 6 de ma voix oui les
françois a même dit quand vous troubliez
le calme aux deux lits d'une façon
scandaleuse six missions ou france ne
connaissez pas casimir n'a jamais pu
inventer une phrase pareille c'est bon
j'ai compris ou ne voulait plus que
chose mes vocalises dans l'île
pas mal mais si mais si
mais au contraire je fasse mes vocalises
encore mais à une condition au lac elle
mon petit gars ont su très bien que vous
fassiez une vocalise en cas d'accident 2
en cas de noyade et trois en cas d
incendie
kazemi
[Musique]